Stan we're getting a lot of mixed
signals coming out of the housing market
so on the on the bearish side we've got
falling homeownership yesterday we saw
some sort of soggy existing home sales
got very strong new home sales what's
your overall read on the housing market
right now well I think we're still in a
recovery phase so certainly the February
existing home sales numbers the which
were positive was better than the
January numbers which we saw a strong
dip and he's at home sales and we are
expecting later on today new home sales
were expecting to be down slightly we're
seeing a slight upward trend in interest
rates and new home sales are more
sensitive to interest rates than
existing home sales and insisting home
sales generally are doing about as well
as we can expect given pretty anemic
income growth house information-- rates
are starting to slowly recover but
there's still a long way from where they
should be and then of course we've still
got Millennials who are delaying
marriage and having kids why what a what
a rising rates going to do to the
housing recovery well I think that you
know it's maasai I'm cautiously
optimistic about what rates are gonna do
to the housing market I think that
broadly speaking when rates rise it
should be because we're starting to see
incomes rise as well so it should be
offsetting there and I'm a little bit
concerned quite frankly that most buyers
right now in a lot of markets are
looking at these home prices through
this distorted lens at very low mortgage
rates which lead them to oftentimes bit
up the price of housing more than they
should be so if you look at Southern
California the bay area for example
those are markets that only look
affordable because of very low rates and
I really want homebuyers to start to
look at home grades rise home prices
will reversal though will come down a
little bit I don't have a reverse but
you're going to start to see home prices
instead of rising at ten fifteen percent
like you are and some of these really
overheated markets right now they're
going to start to slow way down to more
reasonable rates Stan we looked at how
that data from Department Housing and
Urban Development about a week ago and
we found some stuff that surprised us
which is that we would have assumed that
home homes were getting smaller than
people were simplifying but it turns out
that's just something you find on the
culture section of the New York Times
people are actually building larger
houses what's driving that that's right
yeah it's actually it's more than an 80
year trend now towards larger and larger
homes we saw about a one to two year
decline in that right after
housing bubble popped but after that it
went back to its 80 year plus you know
increase where people are just you know
wanting bigger and bigger homes and so
there's nothing economic driving that
that's cultural that's entirely cultural
and a lot of it has to do with the
privatization of our leisure time and
everything else where instead of
spending times in bowling alleys or out
at the Rotary Club or Kiwanis okay we're
family spend their time in their homes
now so therefore they want media centers
they want you know larger living rooms
great rooms they're spending all their
time in their in their homes now that's
really because I mean we're hearing
staggering statistics that you know the
net worth of a 25 to 35 year old is much
lower than normal because they're
sitting on these you know piles of debt
is that playing a role in new household
formation you know I think we're student
debt it's it's really an issue where it
is causing some delay particularly among
the Millennial class and homeownership
but it's just that it's a delay because
what we find is that having completed a
college education of course your your
your your salary is commit certainly
higher and therefore you're in a better
position to actually own a home so I
think net net is going to being a wash
because what people are delaying it
while they're getting more education
they've been getting more education
because the job market has been so bad
and as you see wages pick up that's
right and as you get to college
education they'll be making more money
and that's going to actually yield
higher household formation rates and
more homeownership in the in the future